representative Bernie Sanders
independent of Vermont yesterday that
Democrats criticized the president over
the domestic agenda he in turn
criticized some Democrats in the Rose
Garden Lou I agree with them both both
parties are doing a terrible job in
dealing with the domestic crises but I
didn't mean today you've answered my
question I was just going to ask as the
independent member of Congress what do
you make of all that well I think the
Democrats are doing a terrible job and
the Republicans are somewhat worse there
are enormous crises facing our people
and the situation in terms of our
domestic domestic issues are so bad that
in what disturbs be so much is that
people are giving losing faith
completely in the American political
system you know that in the last
congressional elections in 1990
sixty-five percent of the american
people didn't vote and if the democrats
and republicans keep acting the way
they're acting by running away for the
most important problems facing our
country they're going to give an
election and no one's going to come out
to vote let's look at the issues i mean
we are a nation whose standard of living
is declining I mean they don't talk
about that too much we are becoming a
poor nation our working people today are
earning twenty percent less than then
they earned 20 years ago we are losing
significant sections of our
manufacturing sector and our kids are
going out flipping hamburgers at
McDonald's for minimum wage do you think
that Democrats the Republicans have an
industrial policy which will rebuild
America they really do not in terms of
the tax policy of this country what we
have seen in the last ten years as the
richest 1% of the population have seen
an eighty-six percent increase in their
real income okay the richest people are
becoming much richer meanwhile the
working class the middle class of
becoming poorer now all over America
people say let's see the rich are
getting richer middle class and the poor
are getting poorer maybe we should
suggest that the rich what today paying
less in taxes than they did ten years
ago maybe they might be asked to pay
more in taxes the working class the
middle class they were getting poorer
might be asked to pay less in taxes
rather than more but unfortunately that
idea has not hit the Congress yet or the
issue of health care which I want to
pursue we are one of two nations
in the entire industrialized world that
do not have in one form or another a
national health care system guaranteeing
health care to all of our people I sit
on John Conyers a government operations
committee we have held several hearings
comparing the Canadian healthcare system
which is universal which is
comprehensive which is much more
cost-effective with our system which is
totally out of control are you would
think that the Congress would now be
prepared to stand up to the insurance
companies the pharmaceutical companies
the AMA the medical equipment suppliers
and say fine let's move toward a
canadian-style national health care
system well some of us are pushing that
now be delighted to talk about the bill
that I brought before the Congress but
to be very frank with you I don't think
we have a whole lot of support for that
yet the people are going to have to
stand up and say we want national health
care so I could go on and on the
distribution of wealth in this country
the fact that we our cities and towns
are major cities of literally falling
apart a disintegrating while the federal
government has turned its back in terms
of providing aid for education of
infrastructure improvement and so forth
and so on so I find it interesting
Democrats you know could criticize the
Republicans Republicans criticized the
Democrats they're putting the American
people to sleep the American people are
giving up on Congress than giving up on
what's happening in Washington we need
some fundamental changes and in my view
as I've expressed for many years I think
we need a new political party a third
party which brings together labor and
working people and poor people and
senior citizens and women and minorities
environmentalists peace activists all
those people who today are understanding
quite clearly that Congress is not
representing their interests you
mentioned health care that's a prime
interest of yours what what do you see
on Capitol Hill to give you optimism
that there will be a change well let me
give you the good news first the good
news is that there is increased
discussion about the crisis and let me
just touch on some of the aspects of the
crisis and I think I don't have to tell
the American people as they know better
than we do first thought in our nation
over 35 million Americans have no health
insurance whatsoever that means people
get ill they have an accident they go to
the hospital they're going to be paying
off those bills for god knows how long
in addition to that you have another 50
million Americans who
only partial insurance so they end up in
the hospital they say boy I'm covered
but what ends up happening is they're
gonna have to pay thousands of dollars
for their health care bills and what
that means is by the way among other
things is that studies indicate that
about twenty-five percent of American
people hesitate delay going to the
doctor or the hospital because they're
afraid of the bill so what happens if
you're sticking your delay going to the
doctor guess what you get sicker the
bill is larger you may end up dying
senior citizens are in very serious
trouble are they are spending despite
Medicare eighteen percent of their
incomes on a health insurance on health
care needs in my own state of Vermont
blue cross blue shield just is in the
process of raising what they call
medicom which covers non-medicare
related health care needs by twenty four
percent that's going on all over the
country terms of prescription drugs of
course the prescription drugs is going
off the wall I don't know how many
viewers know that the same prescription
drugs that are manufactured in this
country are sold in Canada are sold in
Europe far far cheaper than they are in
the United States because we don't have
a national health care system which
stands up to the drug companies we're
getting ripped off in that respect now
in addition we have an infant mortality
rate in this country which is 22nd in
the world 22nd in the world now we used
to be 23rd but East Germany merged with
West Germany so we've moved up to 20
second that is a national disgrace life
expectancy we're 12th in the world that
means they're 11 other countries where
the people live longer now having said
all of that people may say well the
reason that we have so many uninsured
people the reason that infant mortality
is so I we're just not spending enough
money but obviously that is not the
answer the fact of the matter is we are
spending far far far more than any
country on Earth and to me what we have
got to do in fact I don't know Lou if
you if you can show this this is a graph
which indicates the amount of money we
spent over here Canadians spend the
second amount that's forty percent less
and then you go on down so we are
spending far more than any other country
on Earth and yet we're getting a very
little out of it clearly I think the
solution must be a movement toward a
single pay
universal comprehensive health care are
similar to what exists are in Canada
people say that the Canadian system has
problems it does but if we understand
they are spending forty percent less per
capita than we are I think by level
funding healthcare at the present level
of 756 billion we can eliminate
virtually all of those problems going to
have the best healthcare system in the
world where every man woman and child
has all of the health care that they
need without any out-of-pocket expense
and what we have got to do is move
toward a single-payer system which
essentially says to the 1,500 private
insurance companies thank you you've had
your day we can no longer afford to keep
you as you may recall there was a study
that just came out last week by the
Government Accounting Office the GAO
which suggested that if we move toward a
single-payer system we would save some
67 million dollars by eliminating all of
the building practices what's going on
in this country you go to a hospital
you're getting billed and you have Blue
Cross and you have Connecticut General
and you have travelers it is enormously
confusing for the hospitals for the
doctors and everyone spending all of
their time and money building us
encounter you have a single payer walk
into the hospital you don't pay anything
maybe the telephone bill is what they
charge you so the direction must be
single payer eliminating the private
insurance companies and also with the
single payer you can have some real cost
containment uh so that's that's what
we're IM working very hard on in
Congress now the good news is there is
more discussion than ever about that in
Congress the bad news is is that I
really don't believe that the Congress
will have the courage to ultimately
stand up to the insurance companies and
the drug companies and the AMA and the
big money health industry people they
have a lot of power they put a lot of
money into packs and I don't think that
Congress is as presently constituted can
stand up to it my hope is that all over
America by the millions senior citizens
work is middle class people all people
begin to say hey this system is no
longer working we need national health
care and basically say I'm not voting
for any member of Congress was not
prepared to support a single-payer
comprehensive universal national health
care system good evening welcome to our
program our guest
evening is a representative Bernie
Sanders he's an independent member the
only independent member of Congress
representing Vermont elected at-large
and we invite you to join our discussion
with him phone numbers at the bottom of
your screen to 0 to 6 to 8 25 25 if
you're in the eastern or central time
zone and out west it's 20 278 3 27 27
prior to coming to Congress Bernie
Sanders was mayor of Burlington Vermont
from 1981 to 1989 and before we take our
first call a congressman let me ask you
were with us in December talking about
your election as an independent before
we take that first call let me ask you
your thoughts now as an independent
member here in Congress what do you
think of Congress as an institution now
that you've seen it for a few months so
I have two thoughts on a personal level
I have been pleasantly surprised by the
friendship and the warmth the warmth by
which other members of Congress have
responded I didn't know that that would
be the case and that's the plus side but
on the political side Lewis as I
mentioned a moment ago in my view
Congress is just very very far out of
touch with the problems facing
working-class Americans elderly people
or poor people you really don't get the
feeling that there is a sense of urgency
you know we have people who standard of
living is declining people sleeping out
on the street in my state the family
farmers are endangered specie they may
lose their farms all kinds of enormous
problems you just don't have the feeling
that Congress is prepared to respond
vigorously they're living in another
world and I'm sorry to say that but that
is my first calls from here in
Washington DC good evening good evening
Bernie at first I want to tell you that
I know you have a lot of support out
there in the United States and I greatly
appreciate my family grace greatly
appreciates what you're trying to do and
keep it up and my question is what role
should the media be playing to help
advance the Public Interest agenda in
this country thank you well you've
touched on an issue that it's worth a
whole of the show the role of the media
in American politics and so forth and
let me take that opportunity to
congratulate c-span and i would say that
c-span has done as much as any media in
this country to open up the process to
allow people to observe what's going on
in Congress to allow for serious
discussion and having all points of view
on your show and I want
congratulate you on the other hand what
we really have to say that in terms of
the corporate controlled media what
we're seeing is news as entertainment
you see I can get on this show when
people can disagree and we can have a
serious debate because we have time I
cannot express nor can any member of
Congress nor can any serious person a
point of view in six seconds I think to
be honest with you as we fight for a
third party as we fight to bring the
people into the process we have got to
make television itself and corporate
control of the media itself a major
political issue the fact is that more
and more of the media is are being owned
by fewer and fewer large corporations
who I do not believe are interested
allowing serious discussions of the
major crises facing our country Laurel
Maryland good evening good evening I'm
thank you I've got two quick questions
for the congressman one is them I know
that your termed and independent now in
terms of political party but I know your
roots are in socialism and that you've
run as a socialist before on one
question is why do you not trumpet that
more in in your causes and what you try
to do and the other question is I know
that many southern democrats were
opposed to you entering the house
Democratic caucus and in that regard I
was wondering how you feel about your
treatment seeing that affair thank you
okay good questions I am a Democratic
Socialist the gentleman is quite right I
am an independent for political purposes
in the sense that i'm not a democrat and
i'm not a republican that is how i am
listed in the directory not that's
appropriate you know we don't go around
saying this gentleman here the
congressman from georgia is a capitalist
we don't say that we say is a Republican
or a Democrat in that sense I'm an
independent but I have no problem saying
in bidding as everybody knows i am a
Democratic Socialist in the sense of
Swedish social democracy in the sense of
the New Democratic Party in Canada which
may affect become the next government of
candidates in the sense of Austrian
social democracy Western Europe social
democracy I think we have a lot to learn
from those countries countries like
Sweden for example which have excellent
national health care system free college
education for their kids which
five weeks paid vacation for all of
their workers which I've had Labor
Government's for 51 out of the last 58
years we can't emulate Sweden or Austria
but there's much to be learned from
those countries to me socialism means
democracy and means representing the
interests of working people and poor
people Ventura California good evening
good evening mr. Sanders yes you're
discussing whether trying to raise the
issue with the American public in
regards to health care and getting them
angered enough to do something I pulled
over 7,000 doors in my congressional
district and found one only five people
who disagree with the idea of one payer
system two issues which I stressed out
of many in those conversations at the
door was the fact that they both we
collect almost 700 billion but the best
number i could get out of Washington the
healthcare finance committee I think to
AARP was 220 billions spent in the
entire medical industry which leaves a
huge discrepancy between what we collect
take out of the economy and give it to
primary health insurance and then we
don't we have to buy that money back to
use it again for something else now that
that would pay for the savings of own
crisis two or three times over secondly
the way we collect it is probably the
cruelest way of all I met more people
who were working we didn't have any
health insurance at all and yet every
time they bought a a car like a Chrysler
there's 700 hours they paid for somebody
else's health insurance thanks
California the gentleman is right and I
I can only say that in my own state we
have we have recently in the state of
Vermont held public hearings around the
state we're a small state and we have
gone to towns which have a few thousand
people and recently in bennington
vermont white river junction from 150
people came out workers and farmers and
elderly people i think and the polling
shows it i mean this is not what that
gentleman says what I'm saying the
polling shows the people of this country
want to move toward a national health
care system they look favorably upon the
Canadian system and what I say to the
viewers is call up your Congressman and
ask him if he's prepared to support
single-payer national health care and if
he or she is not you know given tell
them that you may not be interested in
voting for them again
pensacola florida good evening good
evening I've got a question for mr.
Sanders what I could tell from the
American voter that American voter
actually is shying away from big
government spending and uh well now
there is a health crisis in the country
I know I work in a hospital but I was
wondering don't you think the perhaps
federally subsidized insurance is a much
more rational and much safer step at
this time than than than huge a huge
government program okay let me respond
in two ways our beef to be cost
effective and to be able to get a handle
on the rapidly escalating cost of health
care we must develop a single-payer
system if you simply throw more money
into the program for example if somebody
comes here and says look you know I want
to do something about 35 million
Americans who have no health insurance
let's put 50 billion dollars into that
and cover those people well it in one
way we're delighted to see uninsured
people covered but on the other way what
we know is we're throwing good money
after bad money because the system is
out of control we have to get a handle
on why health insurance costs are going
up fifteen or twenty percent every year
right now the physicians for national
health care recently estimated that we
could save a hundred billion dollars a
year if we move toward a single-payer
system if we eliminate all of that
building the advertising the profit
taking that exists and the model is
there in Canada our second of all well
that's the main thing I think you need a
single-payer system which can control
the cost to health care second of all in
terms of the program that I'm advocating
and this is important it is just as the
Canadians do it the Canadians don't have
one health care program for all of their
provinces what they have is each
province has certain guidelines of its
single-payer it's universal its
comprehensive each state may each
province makes the decisions as to how
they best want to raise their money and
they administer the program that is the
program that I'm advocating as well
Melbourne Florida good evening yes I
would like to comment on the Canadian
system 12 years or 14 years ago when I
live
in Toronto i think i paid eighteen
dollars per month for family coverage
and around that time I remember that
Senator Ted Kennedy I was holding
sessions in Congress and people from
Canada were invited to come down to
appear before his house committee
talking about comprehensive national
insurance program for the United States
and I have been living in the United
States now since 1979 and here we are in
1991 still talking about the subject and
we have got nowhere and just as another
comment while I was at the University of
Illinois I remember there was a young
fellow from Wisconsin and he made a
point and you know Shakespeare says that
many I choose is oftentimes poke me in
jest and he said that the United States
had the best government that money could
buy and I just would like to hear your
guest comment and those two issues thank
you well in one point that I want to
make a tangential to what the gentleman
said is is what polls that are done in
which ask Americans asked the English
people they asked the Canadians how do
you feel about your health care system
what the polls show is that very clearly
our nation the people in our nation our
most dissatisfied with our health care
system when the Canadians who used to
have our system by the way are asked
would you like to go back to the
American system all of three percent say
they would and there are problems within
the Canadian system that's clear but
people are by and large fairly well
satisfied and if we understand when we
compare the Canadian system to the
American system you're not comparing
apples to apples they are spending forty
percent less per capita than we are
spending and yet their system is working
better for them that our system is
working for us the gentleman asked about
the United States having the best system
the money could buy
I think basically he's right and I think
the reason that we do not have a
national health care system right now is
that you have many members of Congress
who have received money pack money from
insurance companies the AMA the
pharmaceutical companies and basically
are not prepared to stand up to those
special interests and that takes us the
whole other issue of campaign finance
reform which moves the United States in
the direction that most democracies in
the world now accept and that is that
money cannot be allowed to buy elections
if I'm a millionaire and you're a
working class person I should not be
able to outspend you ten to one because
I have more money than you do we should
have a level playing field we need to
radically control the amount of money
that's being spent we need public
financing of Elections we need to open
the airwaves to all candidates how did
you finance your last election i
financed most of our money came from
individual contributions we received I
was outspent in terms of PAC
contributions about four to one but we
received money from labor unions and
environmental groups so we have accepted
PAC money from those people who were
prepared to defend and support workers
environmentalist peace activists Reno
Nevada good evening hello I have three
quick questions that are real important
and I want to say Mr Sanders I respect
you a lot and and thank God you there I
and I love mr. Dorgan to I would run for
an independent president byron Dorgan is
one of the very best members of the
conversations define representative for
the people and let them know we
appreciate that to you guys they're both
of yours best I like to ask you I
understand that there was first of all
this Congress believe that this
administration that we know has had
covert activities and used drug money
funded by drug money we had that come
out in Contra hearings do they think
that they should take our rights when we
already have the search and seizure it
seems like it's almost like there's a
new doctrine in the police departments
that everybody's starting to notice that
it's just becoming a like a police state
another thing is nexon head eagleton
resigned from the CIA and he had first
almost 20 years they had seriously
looked for a mole within the CIA they
said that there was a war deception and
that the Soviets plan to go through the
CIA ruin and infrastructure right the
economy and take our constitutional
rights away and it sure does things like
this is the scenario that's going on
right now and did Congress pass a bill
that authorized the things that went on
in the Contra affairs and this covert
secrecy that Congress is allowing to go
on in our government thanks for the call
right now a lot of guys ever think if I
understand the question if the question
was the Congress recently approved an
intelligence appropriation which did not
effectively deal with the issues raised
by Iran Contra I think the caller is
right raleigh north carolina yeah
evening how are you doing good sir I
have a quick question for the gentleman
he his opinions and his stance on issues
don't seem to be too different from
democratic responses and I think they'd
like to see everything goes through the
federal government and I would like to
see things place more in the hands of
the states because I believe there's
more of an oversight there and right now
so much stuff goes to the federal
government if it's going through the
state's you know how exactly how much is
being spent in the state you're able to
call you representative a lot easier
than calling somebody or contacting
somebody in federal government and you
also aren't able to again no clearly how
much your panga well I should I pay for
some he mentioned reparations and
repairing cities the federal government
should be in that business but why
should someone in North Carolina have to
reconstruct north new york city's
streets of bridges or roads thanks for
the call rolling okay well two questions
if the gentleman had heard me earlier I
was the mayor of the city of burlington
for eight years and was one of the
leaders in my state for the local
control the understanding that
grassroots democracy
real democracy means the people have to
have access to the information have to
have empowerment have to be able to
implement ideas so I don't disagree with
them now in terms of for example the
national health care legislation that I
am proposing if the gentleman was here
at the early part of the program what he
would have heard is that under my plan
the federal government will mandate
single-payer you have to do that it has
to be comprehensive it has to be
universal but it will be the states that
administer the program not the federal
government it will be the states that
determine how they collect their local
share their statewide share not the
federal government for precisely the
reasons that the gentleman indicated in
terms of why should North Carolina be
concerned about the problems of New York
City we are one nation are not 50
separate nations and I think if and also
the federal government has the
capability of raising revenue in many
instances in a more progressive manner
than the states do in my view the
federal government should be playing a
very strong role in funding education so
that school districts all over this
country have the capability of well
educating the kids without being
dependent upon regressive local taxes we
have the we have the obligation to make
sure that all of our kids could afford
to go to college there are many
important responsibilities that the
federal government must tackle Durham
North Carolina good evening yes another
call from North Carolina just a few
miles away from Raleigh I would just ask
congressman Sanders that if he cares for
the democratic socialism of Sweden so
much that he tell the American people
they have a basically a about a seventy
percent marginal tax rate in Sweden and
that that ought to be known and in
addition to that I am extremely happy
that he's listed in it as an independent
when I see his votes every day on c-span
so I can see where he votes and one
other point you ought to listen to Rush
Limbaugh every day because you're you're
the joke of the house representatives
well in some circles Rush Limbaugh is
the joke that we talked about sigh I'm
not offended by that uh in terms of the
Swedish tax rate in fact
the marginal rate is going down there's
a lot of debate and Sweden but what the
gentleman forgot to talk about is the
government there which is in power the
social democratic government has been in
power I believe for 51 out of the last
58 years and if they're such a terrible
government and if they are pressing
their people so much I wonder why they
haven't been thrown out now with the
gentleman forgets to talk about is that
in Sweden yes they pay more in taxes I
mean in fact you're not going to have a
national health care system unless you
have a tax base to support unless you
are paying more in taxes but and I'm not
here you should get the Swedish
ambassador on actually knows a lot more
about Sweden and I go but what we should
also be included when the Swedish people
go to the hospital they don't pay for it
when the Swedish people when they have
children and they take parental leave
they get a year off without any with
with full pay so that they can well
educate they can take care of the kids
and nurture of their children workers
they have five weeks paid vacation
workers on the job have a lot more to
say about what's going on college
education is virtually free so they got
paying taxes but you know what they're
getting something for the taxes that
paying for in this country many people
are paying a lot in taxes we're not
getting all that much back he is
determining both the marginal tax rate
is all u % yeah so so everybody's not
paying so of course and of course that
would be they have a progressive tax
system in fact as I understand that the
marginal tax rate is going down several
years ago we used to have a marginal tax
rate I think not not all that
differently but let me be also clear
about the issue about taxes let me tell
that gentleman that in the last 10 years
the very richest people in this country
have become much richer their tax rates
have declined I have no problem with
asking the wealthiest people in this
country to pay significantly more in
taxes Stockton California good evening
yes congressman I like to submit to you
that the only enemy that American people
really faces the very government we have
taxation without representation or
credibility we have four or five pure
justice system we call traders heroes we
are constantly being besieged by with
the lead from the federal government on
our constitutional rights which are
being suspended and oppressed
uh work what I'd like to know is is
military going to back the federal
government against American people
eventually or is this your thing is
going to be cleared up at one time or
another without any bloodshed because
the way you people men are going at it I
think the only thing you do have is on
revolution congressman oh well this
gentleman thinks the situations he
thinks it's worse now I do not think
that the military is going to be taking
over the government Memphis good evening
good evening mr. Sanders you make such
good sense and speak so clearly of the
issues that I wonder that I'm not
surprised that Congress has difficulty
understanding they have made such a mess
of this situation as a nurse I see it
every day for instance last week I saw a
family signed an agreement to pay forty
dollars a month for hospital care
totaling about sixty thousand dollars
for a child who would be dead within a
year that makes you sick in addition to
the drug companies in the insurance
companies which I feel are probably the
worst enemies you have what about the
medical profession am I in the minority
when I see this so clearly or are they
coming around well let me give you the
good news in the bad news the good news
is that for those doctors who are
interested in practicing medicine rather
than just making a lot of money what
those doctors are seeing is that it is
becoming harder and harder for them to
practice real medicine in other words
they want to prescribe a prescription
drug to somebody as part of the
treatment you know what that person
can't afford the prescription drug
they've got to change the nature of
their treatment they think a patient
should need a B and C type of treatment
the patient can't afford it so for
serious physicians now they are
beginning to come on to a national
health care concept because they want to
practice real medicine in Vermont
recently and again we're a small state
125 physicians assigned a petition a
letter published in the newspaper saying
we believe in the concept of national
health care on the other hand we should
not kid ourselves that you have certain
groups of physicians especially the
specialists are the people who are
making
whole lot of money out of medicine they
will like they will not like national
health care and I think they'll oppose
us very strongly Meridian Mississippi
good evening um yes good evening
representative Sanders I really like the
way you talk I'm wondering our
representative thad Cochran and trent
lott or republicans and they support
rubber stamp everything that President
Bush says or does and what I'm wondering
is that this base closure issue is not
another attempt to make everyone fear
that the economy is going to fail in
their area in order to at the last
minute say oh well your representative
got the base to remain open and we're
going to keep him in office you know to
support all that and I think this is the
master manipulation that our president
bush as part of the CIA at one time he
was the information specialist is so
good at doing it Bank figured this out i
know he's thought of it well I honestly
don't know all that much about it I
think what people have feared and I
won't comment more on that is is the
possibility of politics intruding on the
base closing I hope it doesn't and I
can't comment more on it i mean what you
don't want to see is certain political
people being punished by having bases
and their neighborhoods and their
districts being closed and other people
not we hope that the base closing is
done on a fair and objective manner
denver good evening good evening uh as
someone who grew up in the 60s and 70s i
really was kind of disillusioned during
the recent persian gulf conflict and i'd
like to explain briefly why it seems to
me that during that time many people who
describe themselves as liberals special
liberal democrats and on the left side
of the spectrum and protocol spectrum in
general were definitely against the war
and then just a few months ago people
like Steven so Lars and many other
former quotes liberals all of a sudden
became warmongers and i must say that it
seems to me that there's some kind of
racism involved in the sense that the
Vietnamese were not worthy of defending
against communism but yet countries in
the Middle East were worthy of being
defended
in sending American troops and I must
say also i'm very disillusioned that
many people in the Jewish community at
it seems to me a lot of hypocrisy and it
seems to be also that the media just
went along with this like a football
game cheering cheering on the troops
whereas 20 years ago in Vietnam the
meeting was told seem to be dead set
against the Vietnam conflict Denver
thanks very much for the call covered a
lot of ground okay I let me just start
off last and work back I think the point
about the media being a cheerleader
rather than an objective observer I
think is true i think i've read analyses
of the types of coverage that the media
presented the corporate media and major
networks and was by no means an
objective what it was basically is it
was we rather than an objective analysis
in terms of the war in general all that
I can say is I consistently opposed the
war I thought that especially now that
the Cold War had ended ended that the
World through the united nations would
be able to resolve international
disputes especially you know you had a
situation with the Saddam Hussein is a
very evil guy there's no question about
it his invasion of Kuwait was absolutely
wrong but with the whole world united
against this guy wasn't there any other
way that we could have defeated him
could have gotten them out of Kuwait
other than by a major war and while you
know people celebrate the victory of the
war and we applaud the armed forces for
the very great effectiveness but should
not be minimized which should not be
forgotten is probably we don't know for
sure some 300,000 people died in that
war Iraqis women and children they are
still dying the infrastructure of Iraq
was wiped out children today are
drinking filthy water the hospitals have
been wiped out their electrical system
has been wiped out in addition to that
the environment has suffered a terrible
blow air pollution the Persian Gulf
itself is now heavily polluted the cost
of the war we have 30,000 children in
the world starving to death every day
and yet tens and tens of billions of
dollars was spent on this war so I don't
you know this war I believe I think the
goal of getting Saddam Hussein out of of
Kuwait up
could have been accomplished without the
war that was my view them my view
remains that way Margate New Jersey good
evening yes good evening I'd like to
just make some observation in reference
to what was just said right now I feel
this is strictly President Bush bush
wants to have people that he is very
familiar with dealing with you know in
other words he knows his enemy he knows
how Saddam Hussein operates he knows how
it operates in China he knows how Gorby
operates these are the people that he
has worked with for many years
especially when he was head of the CIA
so that's what he wanted to keep with
but I primarily called about the
national health care some observations
they wanted to make is one we do have
excellent health care coverage in this
country for the top 1% in this country
period that's it and the doctors
themselves secondly last night on PBS
Peter Jennings hosted health quarterly
in it they stated a fact that it was
said by the year 2000 the average
employee will cost are you ready for
this twenty-two thousand dollars in
health benefits alone now can you
imagine what the individual health care
costs will be there and the third
observation I want to make is if if we
go from decentralizing to nationalizing
we are going to get a whole slew of
little clinics which will look like
jack-in-the-boxes you're going to drive
in you're going to get two aspirins
you're going to get your your your
temperature taken and your blood
pressure and they're going to say that's
it and kick you out i mean i've seen a
couple of these already on television
and their little Mickey Mouse boxes and
it reminded me of a character of a
jack-in-the-box driving thanks New
Jersey I'm not quite sure I understood
the third point the second point though
in terms of a the tremendous inflation
that we're seeing and health insurance
costs she's absolutely right and that is
and that raises a whole other issue that
we didn't discuss in the fact that we
are becoming less competitive as a
nation because you know the American
automobile industry is spending I think
more for
health insurance per car than layoffs or
steal per car so i think that the woman
raises a very good question i think if
her point was that if present trends
continue and people don't have the money
to get quality health care what you are
going to see and i think i understood
what you saying you're going to really
see not good care available because
that's just the best that people can
afford ultimately what we as a nation
have got to say is is healthcare a right
of all people or is it a privilege of
the rich and I think we could learn a
lot from the Canadians and say we can
have a one tier system quality health
care for all people and the good news is
that by moving toward a single-payer
system we could have quality health care
for all people without spending one
penny more than the 756 billion dollars
we're presently spending I am not
advocating increased spending we could
have quality health care for all people
given the enormous amount of money we're
presently spending Shelburne Vermont
good evening hi I would tend to disagree
that the government is the final answer
in all this this is the same government
that in their procurement of toilet
seats for submarines goes to exorbitant
cost is the same government that in
managing housing for poor people whom
representative Sanders seems to think
he's the guardian angel of hid the you
know there's a housing is no good you
can't go in and work with that agency at
all the only thing that has spiraled
higher in costs in the last ten years
than medical cost is the cost of our
government so why should the government
be more efficient at managing costs than
anybody else okay let me answer that's a
very fair question and it's good to get
it from my home state there are the
answer is very clear that if it's not
necessarily that the government does it
more efficiently than than the private
sector although if you look right now
Medicare and Medicaid are run far more
administrative Lee efficiently in terms
of cost then is blue cross blue shield
in the private insurance companies the
Canadians are spending just a tiny
fraction in terms of administration of
their healthcare system and it's not
because they're better it's because of
everybody has the same care and you
don't have to build people for Blue
Cross
blue shield in Connecticut General and
travelers it necessarily is more
efficient the fact is quite clear that a
single-payer national health care system
is far more efficient than the chaotic
system that we have right now and while
I will not disagree with the caller that
the government does many terrible things
let's not overdo about a wonderful
private sector and the S&L fiasco and
the crooks in the banking industry who
ripped this country off to a degree that
even the government can't begin to catch
up with del mar california good evening
yes I'd like to inject a little
scientific note into the proceedings I'm
afraid that Mr Sanders is comparing
apples with oranges when he compares our
system with the Canadian national health
system if he thinks that we can have
done about their system in the first
place the overage over 65 age group in
Canada is twenty percent larger than in
the United States nine point eight
percent versus 12.1 % and this segment
of the population is responsible for
three and a half times the health care
costs of the general population second
point blacks and hispanics make up
twenty percent of our population less
than one percent of Canada's and the
minority groups because of crime drugs
gangs cause a disproportionate amount of
health care costs age is the leading
cause of death among black women aged 25
to 39 in New York City the greatest
cause of death in black males 15 to 24
is homicide as a matter of fact the
incidence of teenagers killed by guns is
seventeen hundred percent higher in the
United States than in Canada thanks for
the call well that tells us also a lot
about Canadian society versus American
society and the degree of crime and
violence that exists here the gentleman
is not right there may be difficult
there are population differences but
what we are talking about is that the
Canadians are providing health insurance
to every man woman and child with
virtually no out-of-pocket expense
they're providing free prescription
drugs in most provinces as i understand
it for their senior citizens
and they're doing that at forty percent
less per capita than we are now there
are those people and as the debate
becomes heated up you're going to see on
television all the people telling us
just how different Canada is from the
United States the fact of the matter is
that the Canadian system is working if
we spend more money on our system than
the Canadians are on their system we can
eliminate some of the problems that they
have that is the direction to go with
the gentleman cannot argue against is
that medical procedures encounter you
want to go into an appendectomy and
Canada far cheaper than it is in the
United States drugs in the prescription
drugs in Canada far cheaper than in the
United States administrative costs far
cheaper in Canada than in the United
States now we're going to have opponents
the insurance companies and the
pharmaceutical companies are going to
fight back but I think the facts are
very clear government operations
committee under John Conyers has been
holding some very interesting hearings
when you look at the facts the Canadian
system is in fact far superior than our
system last call is from Miami Miami we
have just a short time left for a quick
question yes I'd like to talk to you
about the ERISA law and why are our
federal government should not be trying
to place the burden of insurance on the
employer as you saw on the the show that
the lady mentioned last night on PBS was
a man who worked for a company who had a
child well my wife became very ill and
even after I had increased my sales by
three hundred percent they told me that
they had to fire me they told me that
they've done it with another man and
they went ahead it did it so I've
checked out the ERISA law and I want to
know if you think it has enough teeth
and tell explain to people with the
ERISA law is well I can't explain to
people with the ERISA Lord is because
I'm not thoroughly familiar with the
ERISA law but in terms of why the
employers alone I mean there is a bill
it's called Senator Kennedy is bringing
a fourth with Senator Rockefeller and it
would be an employer mandate employ a
mandated health insurance program
basically it would require all employers
are to start paying health insurance and
if they don't provide it for their
workers they have to pay into a special
fund the problem with that approach is
it doesn't begin to get to the cost
containment issue as I indicated earlier
we are wasting between 67 billion
which is the GAO estimate and over a
hundred billion dollars which other
studies have indicated by maintaining
the chaotic system of 1,500 separate
health insurance companies the way to go
to my mind is a single-payer system
which treats all people you're working
you're unemployed you're a senior
citizen you're a pregnant women woman
you know what we all have the same
quality care and we don't differentiate
between those who are employed those are
unemployed those are retired we finally
say in this country if you're an
American citizen you got all the quality
care that you without out-of-pocket
expense and it's covered by the general
tax base representative Bernard Sanders
independent of Vermont thanks very much
thank you very much